قال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه اوليكس فانه
سيستقيل اذا اتخذ الرئيس
الاوكرنسكي مثل هذا القرار واضاف رزمكو في
خلال مؤتمرا صحفيا القراره بشان ما اذا
كان ينبغي ان يكون وزيرا للدفاع ام لا
يتخذه شخص واحد هو الرئيس
في وقت سابق ان رزمكوف قد يتقدم باستقالته
في الايام المقبله وان البرلمان يعتزم
النظر في طلبه في وقت مبكر من الاسبوع
المقبل
لقد كنت على قناعه دوما انه من المستحيل
الاستمرار في منصب ما الى الابد القرار
بشانهما اذا كان ينبغي ان اكون وزيرا
للدفاع ام لا يتخذه شخص واحد والقائد
الاعلى للجيش والقوات المسلحه رئيس
اوكرانيا ذلك حسب الدستور الاوكراني فقط
بقرار من الرئيس سيتخذ قرارات معينه
وسابقى اساعد في وصولنا للنصر وسافعل ما
يقترحه الرئيس عليه لانني ضمن الفريق
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
سيدنا فهل استفحل الفساد في المؤسسات
الاوكرانيه ما يستدعي القيام بحمله
اعتقالات مثل التي يقوم بها
زيلينسكي حاليا
نصمت الواقع هذا ليس كذلك في اوكرانيا منذ
بدايه الحرب كان هناك
الخائنون الذين كانوا ينشروا المعلومات
وروسيا تعتقد انها تستطيع ان تشتري كل شيء
بالاموال وذلك يقوم بتطير النظام منها الى
الاشخاص ولكن الى اي مدى قد يذهب هل سيقيل
وزير الدفاع
يوجد حوار في هذا الموضوع الان وانا
صديق وزير الدفاع شخصيا لدينا اصدقاء
مشتركين كثيرا هو ليس شخص فاسد ولكن لديه
مسؤوليات سياسيه بسبب الازمات السياسيه
التي بدات الان طيب برايك ما تاثير موضوع
الفساد بشكل عام على الحصول مساعدات
عسكريه واقتصاديه غربيه هل تعتقد بان هذا
هذا الموضوع ربما يؤثر على هذه المنح وهذه
المساعدات الغربيه
كنت احلل هذه الامور فعلا ورايت التقارير
ولاي درجه الغرب ينظر سلبين او ايجابيا
الى هذه الامور 60 65 بالمئه ينظرون الى
هذا كشيء ايجابي دليلا على ان اوكرانيا
تحارب الفساد عليكم ان تعلموا ان الفساد
وصل الى القمه في اوكرانيا في عام
2013 عندما كان الرئيس الذي انقلب الذي
ندعناه كان قد وضع يده على جميع الشركات
في اوكرانيا كما كانت الاوضاع في روسيا
كان يقوم بسجن جميع المعارضين على هذا
وقاموا الاوكران بطرده الى روسيا ومنذ ذلك
الوقت بقيت بعض بعض الفساد المالي الذي
نقوم بتطهيره الان منذ ذلك الوقت
واوكرانيا في حاله حرب يعني الوضع في
البلاد في في خطر يعني دلاله مرصدها
في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه التي من
المفترض هي المدافع الاول عن اوكرانيا
وخلال فتره حرب تخوضها اوكرانيا مع روسيا
الحوار الان عن قسم واحد في الوزاره رقموا
بشراء البيض باسعار عاليه جدا ان رئيس هذا
القسم هو من قاموا بطرده
والقبض عليه والان نائبه
عفوا نائب الوزير هو هو المسؤول عن هذا
لذلك الاوكرانيين غير راضيين المجتمع الان
في ضوء الحرب انا وانتم ايضا كلنا منزعجين
ان بعض المجانين والمنافقين في اوقات
الحرب يقوم بهذه الانواع من التصرفات التي
تشبه الروس في الواقع ان هذه الثقافه
الروسيه ونحن نقوم بحربين حرب عسكريه حيث
ندافع عن انفسنا وحرب داخليه حرب ثقافيه
نقوم بسجن المسؤولين عن الفساد التابعين
لروسيا في الواقع
شكرا لك تيمو في
المستشار مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني متحدثا
الينا من كيف